The first 20 plus years of Long Now has
really been us kind of acting as a
start-up and executing on some of the
first projects, like the 10,000 year
Clock, which is nearing completion now in West Texas, and certain library projects
like the Rosetta project. Laura's here
today. She'll be talking a bit about
language and culture as well. And
that first 20 to 25 years, we're now
looking at as Long Now's Q1. And
if that's our Q1 project what is our Q2
project? And when we started this,
we realized very much that engineering
a 10,000 year clock is a difficult problem, but engineering a
ten thousand year institution is really
the hardest problem that we could ever
work on. And so I think that this is
really going to be Long Now's next big
project: how to build long term
institutions. And as I started diving
into it, I realized there's
really no discipline,
there's no broad study of this anywhere.
Nobody is a long-term
institution expert. And so this seems
like the thing for Long Now to do—not
only for ourselves as the first customer
but also for the world.
There has to be some great practices and
knowledge that we can pull together and
be the clearinghouse for this kind of
thing. So this is the very first
gathering in this space. And nobody here
is really from a very long-term
institution necessarily. I think that's
going to be our next one of these
gatherings, is going to be bringing those
people together. But this one is the one
where we get to think very very broadly.
And we're looking at natural systems,
language and culture, some of that
historical precedence of the past and
how these things work. And I've pulled
together my research so far on long-term
institutions. And what I want today to be
as much as possible is a discussion
among all of us.